nous allons parler du potager du rock et
nous recevons ce soir donc Pedro vous
êtes trésorier de l'association
universelle music ainsi que Zitoun
vous-même vous êtes vice-président de
cette association alors le potager du
rock qu'est-ce que c'est le potager du
rock c'est un festival qui se déroule
chaque année à Versailles donc ça va
faire 7 ans à peu près qu'on fait c'est
pour promouvoir sur tous les groupes à
faire ça y est et les groupes alentours
ce sont les autres exactement exactement
jeunes
du rock bon alors j'entends le jeu de
mots peut-être avec le Potager du Roi
est-ce que c'est ça c'est une symbolique
avec Versailles
mais c'est pas que rock c'est de la
musique
alors dites nous par exemple
on pourra trouver quel type de musique
vous pouvez trouver du jazz du rock du
punk La Saule la blouse de du blues
cette année c'est ça qui est comment est
né en fait l'idée de ce festival alors
le festival est né de la fusion de deux
événements à la base donc à 7 ans qui
était un événement qui s'appelait rock
en stock qui était un événement 4
montant si à Versailles et baroque était
un festival dans les bars donc on a
fusionné ces deux événements pour créer
le potager du rock donc il y a 7 ans
maintenant et depuis on était sur un
format d'un mois on aurait dû se format
une semaine pour densifier un petit peu
l'émulation de Versailles quoi et voilà
donc maintenant c'est une semaine de
concert dans différents lieux des bars
des clubs des scènes en plein air est-ce
que c'est gratuit et alors voilà la
plupart du festival est gratuit on a une
date qui est payante cette année
auparavant clôturer le festival par un
concert avec des groupes professionnels
et amateurs au théâtre Montier depuis
l'an dernier on crée un nouvel email un
événement en plein air qui qui lui aussi
gratuit et donc accessible à tous voilà
donc cette année la nouveauté c'est
qu'il y a deux concerts plein air c'est
un 23 sur la plage Charo et un 25 donc
c'est la fameuse date de clôture et là
l'événement donc c'est pas comme l'année
dernière parce que ça aura lieu
dites-nous à la guerre des chantiers
l'an dernier on avait inauguré au
parking de l'Europe et cette année on
met ça garde des chantiers avec une
sélection des groupes qu'on a aimé
notamment ceux de l'an dernier c'est
certain et puis des nouveaux rouges
parce que pour donner le temps pour
avoir une idée justement des groupes qui
vont se présenter on va regarder une
petite compilation donc justement de une
sélection de quelques groupes
l'autorisation les échanges avec les
différents autres partenaires locaux
mais c'est essentiellement logistique et
un petit peu sur la communication aussi
relay un petit peu l'info dans leur
maison de quartier les médiathèques etc
juste revenir sur les groupes on a
entendu un petit extrait vous parler de
ces groupes qui souhaitent devenir
professionnel quel est le niveau les
groupes se débrouillent de mieux en
mieux le choix est de plus en plus
difficile ouais tout à fait oui
carrément chaque année
complètement alors là il y a là pour le
coup il y en a un des il y en a certains
qui sont professionnels sur ce qu'on
vient de voir et effectivement le niveau
augmente il y a de plus en plus de très
jeunes amateurs qui commencent très tôt
la musique il y a de plus en plus de
moyens de les faire travailler leur
musique enfin c'est style de musique là
donc le rock la musique électronique le
jazz etc et donc c'est vrai que le
niveau augmente chaque année on a repéré
certains groupes sur des tremplins aussi
et c'est vrai que des très très bons
groupes quoi alors le côté concert en
plein air est-ce que ça apporte enfin
est-ce qu'il y a un rendu qualitatif
différent de de ce côté un petit peu le
plus intimiste finalement dans les bars
est-ce que vous voyez vous avez une
différence le concert en plein air c'est
pour moi c'est un peu le Graal c'est à
dire que là on touche tout le monde tout
de suite c'est beaucoup plus convivial
enfin c'est c'est plus large quoi c'est
à dire que là on touche à la fois le
public des groupes à la fois le public
et de passage et visibilité plus grande
la visibilité est plus grande voilà
c'est plus c'est dehors c'est assez
libre c'est ça correspond aussi un peu
l'atmosphère de ses concerts quoi ok
donc on rappelle les dates donc c'est du
18 donc ça démarre samedi jusqu'à samedi
prochain le 25 donc toute une semaine de
concert quasiment gratuit
dans un lieu bon on va peut-être le
citer le lieu comme ça
une nouvelle salle de spectacle à
Versailles qui existent depuis deux
trois ans maintenant je crois et qui
propose quelques concerts et surtout
aussi des spectacles des one man show du
Cabaret du théâtre Toulouse mais pour
autant tout le reste donc
parfait donc les les informations se
sont
affichées en tout cas votre site pour
avoir l'intégralité des groupes et puis
pour savoir les thématiques les styles
un petit peu de temps aussi on peut
peut-être regarder à nouveau l'extrait
de ces groupes qui qui participent au
potager du rock ou qui ont participé
c'est le magnéto est toujours calé on va
regarder cet extrait et on se retrouve
ensuite sur le plateau pour la suite de
cette édition du 7 8
alors voilà le potager du rock donc
c'est une semaine de concert à
Versailles et ça déroulera donc du 18 au
25 mai merci à Zitouni Pedro